[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: In the
previous video,
we saw just how important
low latency is when creating
interactive audio experiences.
But how can you actually
achieve this in your app?
In this video, I'll show
you how the Oboe library
helps you to create a
low latency audio stream
for playing sound.
You can play sound
through a number
of different audio devices, such
as the built-in speakers, wired
headphones, USB audio
devices, or over Bluetooth.
An audio stream is
used to move data
from your app to an audio
device so that it can be played.
To create an audio stream, we
use an audio stream builder.
This allows us to set
properties on the stream.
It's best to leave most
properties unspecified to allow
Oboe to pick the optimal values
for the default audio device.
However, to create a stream with
the lowest possible latency,
there are a few properties
which we should always set.
The performance mode should
be set to low latency,
and the sharing mode
should be set to exclusive.
Once the stream
properties have been set,
we can open the stream
by passing a reference
to an audio stream pointer.
Be sure to check the
stream open successfully.
Otherwise, you won't have
a valid stream object.
If there was a problem,
you can convert the error
to a human readable string
using convert to text.
In fact, convert to text can
be used to convert many Oboe
objects to text.
Once the stream has been
successfully opened,
you can start it asynchronously.
You can now send data
to the audio device.
To put data into
an audio stream,
we can either write
directly into it
or have the audio stream
request data using a callback.
Callbacks give us
the lowest latency,
so it's best to use them
for interactive audio apps.
To create a callback object,
subclass audio stream
callback and override
the onAudioReady method.
This method is called when
the audio stream requires
more data.
It has three parameters-- a
pointer to the audio stream
object, a container
array-- which we
can write our audio data into.
This has type void star, because
the format of the audio stream
can either be 16-bit
integers or floats.
It's up to us to cast
to the correct format.
Lastly, numFrames tell us
how many frames of audio
are required.
Each frame contains
one or more samples.
The number of samples will
depend on the streams channel
count.
For example, a stereo stream
has two samples per frame--
one for the left channel and
one for the right channel.
NumFrames also tells
us the maximum time
we have to create the data.
Failure to supply
data within this time
is known as an underrun.
As an example, if
our audio stream
has a sample rate of
48,000 samples per second,
and 192 frames are requested,
this gives us 4 milliseconds
to create this data.
In the real world, we want to
keep well under this deadline
to allow for system
overhead and late callbacks.
To give you the best chance of
meeting this audio deadline,
onAudioReady is called
on a high priority system
thread, which means it won't
be preempted by lower priority
threads.
But it's critical that
you don't do too much work
or block inside this method.
More detailed guidance on
what you should and shouldn't
do here can be found in the
full guide to Oboe on GitHub.
Inside, onAudioReady, we
write the requested number
of audio frames into
the audio data array.
This could be generated
using digital synthesis
or be supplied from
prerecorded audio data.
Finally, return a
data callback result.
This can either
be continue, which
indicates that we want the
callbacks to continue, or stop,
which indicates that
the stream should
stop with no more callbacks.
Once you've finished creating
your callback object,
you can link it to
your stream using
the builder we created earlier.
There's one final
step we need to take
to ensure our audio stream has
the lowest possible latency--
setting its buffer size.
The audio streams buffer
size affects the time
it takes for an audio frame
to travel through the stream
to the audio device.
The larger the buffer,
the longer it takes,
and the higher the latency.
An optimally sized buffer
provides a good trade off
between latency and
underrun protection.
The buffer size must be a
multiple of the stream's burst
size, which is the number
of frames the audio device
consumes in a single read.
A good rule of thumb is to
use twice this burst size.
This means that
if, occasionally,
we miss our audio
callback deadline,
the user will not
hear an audio glitch
as long as the next
callback runs on time.
Use getFramesPerBurst
to get the burst size,
and set buffer size in frames
to set the buffer size.
Now that all the stream
properties are set,
we can start the stream.
Callbacks will
start immediately.
And once you've finished
with the stream,
remember to close it.
After you close a stream, it
cannot be accessed anymore.
You should now
have everything you
need to play audio using a
low latency audio stream.
For a working example, check
out the Hello Oboe" sample
on GitHub, which shows you how
create a simple synthesizer
app.
It also demonstrates how
to handle audio device
changes, such as when the
user connects the headphones.
A link can be found below.
In the next episode,
I'll show you
how to record sound
through a microphone using
low latency input streams.
That's all for now.
So good luck and
go make some noise.
[MUSIC PLAYING]